pues precisamente este viaje del santo
padre se realiza lógicamente con la
invitación del gobierno de irak siempre
cada uno de los viajes debe contar con
la invitación del gobierno al igual que
la iglesia local en ese aspecto lo
importante también para tener en cuenta
es que en el documento de fraternidad
del papá querido el primero puedes
hablar
con los ortodoxos en su momento con el
patriarca bartolomé después quiso
precisamente en emiratos árabes firmar
esa ese acuerdo sobre la fraternidad y
llevarlo al mundo islámico esta visita
histórica precisamente a la llanura de
ur pues
ejemplifica lo que pensó en su momento
dios a través de abra la unión de las
tres iglesias en una sola raíz en una
sola familia ha dicho el papá de
musulmanes de judíos de cristianos en la
cual su mensaje precisamente es un
mensaje de paz en ese mensaje de paz el
papa ha dicho la paz sea contigo a sadam
la cvm porque se ha declarado como un
peregrino penitente para implorar al
señor perdón y reconciliación también
como peregrino de paz ha querido decir
que todos son hermanos y por tanto se
debe rezar juntos y caminar juntos como
también se lo ha dicho en ese mensaje
recorriendo desde roma en el vuelo que
lo llevó a bagdad a cada uno de los
jefes de estado de los países que va
sobrevolando en primer lugar al señor
sergio matar el a presidente de la
república italiana
doña catherine hasta que la presidenta
de la república helénica es decir de
grecia a nicos anastasiades presidente
de chipre a renwick ringler el
presidente del estado de israel a mahmud
abás presidente del estado palestino y a
su majestad abdulá segundo el rey de
jordania entonces es un mensaje en el
que encuentra precisamente a través de
estos presidentes tanto católicos como
cristianos ortodoxos judíos y musulmanes
es decir que recorre también los
territorios de estados y repúblicas en
los cuales hay presencia importante de
cada una de las tres religiones
monoteístas que tienen su origen en esa
llanura de ur que será visitada por el
papá